As for this plane crash,
first of all I want to express my
sincere condolences to all those
who died, this is always a tragedy and
[music]
indeed,
if there were, like,
primary data indicates that there
were company employees there,
I would like to note that these are people who made a
significant contribution to our common  the matter of
fighting the neo-Nazi regime in Ukraine,
we remember this, we know
Prigogine, I knew it a very long time
ago, in the early 90s
[music]
[applause]
and yesterday, as far as I
know, he returned from Africa and
met here with some
officials.
But what exactly is absolutely  The head of the Investigative Committee reported this to me
this morning,
they have
already begun a preliminary investigation into
this incident and it will be carried out
in full and completed
genetic
for a while